الله سبحانه وتعالى خلقنا وامرنا بالصيام
هذا الشهر وجعل ذلك عباده له كل عمل ابن
كل عمل ابن ادم له الا الصوم فانه لي وانا
اجزي به هذا الشهر شهر المنافسه في
المدارسه ومن حقائق رمضان انه شهر
المدارسه كما هو شهر التلاوه المدارسه هنا
يقصد بها مدارسه القران
والمسلمون كما يقراون القران وكما يختمونه
الختمه الاولى والثانيه واكثر لابد ان
يتدارسوه ان يفهموا هذه الايات فهما
جماعيا وفرديا بقراءه الكتاب التفسيري
بحضور مجالس التفسير وايضا المدارسه هنا
بمعنى مدارسه السنه
[موسيقى]
في كل عام يترقب المسلمون بشوق شهر رمضان
وعندما يهل هلال ضيفنا المبارك بقبس نوره
وريح عطوره وروحانيه حضوره نتساءل كيف هي
علاقتنا اليوم بشهر رمضان وكيف يتهيا
المسلمون لاستقباله وما ضرر عدم الاستعداد
لشهر الكريم مرحبا بكم متابعينا في هذه
الحلقه الجديده من بودكاست الجزيره بعد
امس وارحب بضيفي هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور
نور الدين الخادمي رئيس وحده البحوث
بجامعه قطر ووزير شؤون الدينيه السابق في
تونس اهلا وسهلا بك دكتور نور الدين
ورمضان مبارك اهلا وسهلا بك وتحياتي
ودعواتي لجميع المتابعين لهذه الحلقه
ولهذا البرنامج ولهذه المحطه الاعلاميه
الطيبه واسال الله عز وجل وعلا في بدايه
هذا اللقاء وفي بدايه استقداء استقبالنا
لهذا الشهر الفضيل اساله جل وعلا ان
يبلغنا اياه ونحن باتم الصحه والعافيه
والعطاء والوفاء وان يجعلنا فيه من
المقبولين اللهم امين ما احلى ان نبدا
حلقتنا اليوم بهذا الدعاء يا رب ان شاء
الله مستجاب في هذه الايام المباركه دكتور
نور الدين في البدايه نسال سؤال هو لطالما
يتبادر الى ذهننا كيف هي علاقتنا اليوم
بشهر رمضان بسم الله والحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله
العلاقه بالشهر رمضان
علاقه تاريخ
وحاضر ومستقبل علاقه
انسانيه كونيه رمضان هو شهر كوني ارضي
وسماوي شاهد حاضر وغيبي مستقبلي
وصف بانه شهر الامه وشهر محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم
سبحانه وتعالى هو شهر من السنه هو شهر
هجري قمري وهو تتعلق به عباده الصيام
بناء على رؤيه الهلال فهو بناحيه فلكيه
كونيه وبناحيه عباديه شعائريه وبناحيه
حضاريه ثقافيه
اجتماعيه حاليا ومستقبليه تعريفا نعم
دكتور نور الدين طيب كيف هي علاقتنا بكل
هذه الابعاد لهذا الشهر الكريم علاقه
رمضان علاقه الانسان الطفل في اسره تصوم
الانسان
الصائم الشاب الصائم بعد بلوغه سن الرشد
الذي يعلم ابنائه هذا الصيام استمرارا
لسند في الصيام ونحن معشر الامه الاسلاميه
سندنا متعدد عنا سند القران وسند السنه
وسند اللغه العربيه
وسنبدا الحضاره العربيه او سند الاصلاح
العام وعنا ايضا سند رمضان بمعنى ان هذا
الشهر هذه المحطه هي محطه جيل بعد جيل انا
اذكر عندما كنت طفلا صغيرا مع ابي وامي
وجدي وجدتي واخواتي يا اخوتي واخواتي كنت
حقيقه
اتذكر هذه الايام الجميله جدا في مدفع
رمضان واذان رمضان وفي المسحرات هذا الذي
يوقظ الناس للصحور حلويات رمضان
ابريكه رمضان او السمبوسه على اختلاف
العبارات في حسب الاعتبارات الجغرافيه
الاكله الصلاح الهلال
استعداد للعيد كذلك ليله القدر كذلك ليله
النصف ليله
صداقه الميت هذه
الجزئيات
العمليه وهذه المفردات الحضاريه اسهمت هي
شخصيا وفي امثال اسهمت في صياغه طفل
بحراره وثقافه بسند موصول في هذه العباده
التي هي عباده بالاساس ولذلك حلقتنا
برمضان علاقه عباديه بمعنى اننا نعبد الله
سبحانه وتعالى في هذا الصيام وفي قيام
ليله قيام ليل رمضان وفي كل ما هو عباده
وشعائر ولكننا ايضا علاقه اخرى علاقه فيها
العلم الفكر فيها الروح الوجدان فيها
المجتمع والانتظام الاجتماعي التنازل
التضامن فيها ايضا العمران والثقافه
والمنتوج والحضاري كل هذه المفردات تمثل
نظما دقيقا جامعا ممتعا ممتعا لهذا الشهر
المبارك ونحن قد نشئنا في طفولتنا
وتشربنا الصيام في شبابنا
ونستصحب هذا الاصل في
كهولتنا وفي شيخوقتنا وهذا نورثه لابنائنا
واجيالنا كما نحن تشربناه من ابائنا
واسلافنا
دكتور نور الدين في رحله رمضانيه شيء
ذكريات جميله تحدثت عنها
هذا ولمست في كلامك تلك الرغبه والشوق
لشهر رمضان لكن انت قلت كلمه مهمه في
سياقها حديثك عن كل هذه الابعاد لشهر
رمضان المبارك هو انه ان هذا شهر تتناقله
الاجيال جيل بعد جيل ولكن اليوم هناك
انقسام في الامه الاسلاميه دكتور نور
الدين هناك من يتحدث عن وجود اربع مجموعات
من المسلمين لهم اراء مختلفه بخصوص هذا
الشهر المبارك هناك مجموعه يقول لك انه
رمضان لم يعد يتماشى مع مقتضيات العصر
هناك مجموعه اخرى تقول لك انه رمضان هو
فيه مشقه لا تتحملها صحه الانسان
وما شقل فائده منها وهناك مجموعه اخرى
تقول لك لا بالعكس في رمضان هو فرصه للسهر
واللهو والمتعه وغيره يعني ابتسامه جميله
على فكره الدكتور نور الدين وهناك مجموعه
رابعه دكتور نور الدين ترى في رمضان فرصه
تدريبيه للنفس
ولقتناص الفرص
لكل من كل هذه المعاني الجميله في شهر
رمضان
هذا السؤال القيم المعقد الذي حقيقه يمثل
حاله موجوده في امتنا ولكن الحاله الغالبه
العامه في الامه ان رمضان هو فرصه هو محطه
هو اضافه نوعيه للامه رغم ما تمر به
احيانا من معاناه ومكابده وعذابات الذي
اعتبره في هذا التوصيف الرباعي اذا صحت
العباره واجمع بينها هذه الاوصاف وهذه
الحالات الاربع اجمع بينها ضمن كلمتين
كلمه المشقه والفرصه بعض ما ذكرته يتعلق
بان بعض الناس يقولون ان رمضان مشقه مشقه
وعنت
وترك للاكل والشرب واحيانا اضطراب الليل
والنهار وربما فويت بعض العمل وبعض
الانتاج
هذا ملاحظ في الامه يعني في بعض الافكار
في بعض التمثلات لكن هذه المشقه التي هي
جزء من ماهيه التكليف وعماره الارض ليس
هنالك تقدم في اي مجتمع الا وفيه مشق نحن
نتحدث عن المشقه المقدور عليها وفي العلمي
فيها المشقه فوق طاقه كصيام الظهر كله وفي
مشقه مقدور عليها وهي مشقه الصيام في خلال
شهر رمضان ومن طلوع الفجر غروب الشمس هذه
المشقه مثل مشقه اي عمل
الدراسه فيها مشقه بناء المنشات التخطيط
للدوله
الصحه العلاج الجسور الطرقات العمل
الاعلامي التدريس كل هذه اعمال فيها مشقات
ولولا هذه المشقات ما تمت هذه الاعمال وما
حققت اهدافها لذلك المشقه التي نتحدث عنها
في رمضان هي نوعان مشقه مقدور عليها
واصحابها يصومون ومشقه غير مقدور عليها
المرضى والمسافرون والضعفاء وكبار السن
والاسلام جاء بهذا وجاء بذلك لكنني اقول
ننطلق من هذه المشقه التي تمثل تحديا او
تمثل حافزا او دافعا من اجل فرصه للتطوير
والتجاوز والبناء ولذلك رمضان فيه مشقه
ولكن فيه فرصه روحيه في طاقه نفسيه
ابداعيه فرديه وجماعيه طيب دكتور نور
الدين كيف ترد على هذه الانقسامات كيف
تقراها وفي الاخير هناك اختلافات لطالما
كانت هناك اختلافات هو الاختلافات لها
اعتبارها في الفهم وفي الجواب والتفاعل
معها في اطار التصحيح في اطار الاثراء
ولكن الاساس كما قلنا رمضان هو حقيقه
ومحطه لها
علمها ولها انجازاتها نبدا بالامور الجزء
التاريخي والحضاري
الفتوحات الاسلاميه
والمحطات الفاصله بين الامه الاسلاميه
وسائر الامم الاخرى في اطار التدافع
الحضاري التمكين الحضاري الافاده الحضريه
هذه الشواهد التاريخيه تدل على ان رمضان
ليس فيه مشقه تعيق عن المحطات التاريخيه
والحضاريه في صراعها في تدافع ثقافي تدافع
الحضاره الدلو على ذلك من من بدايه
الاسلام في الغزوات والفتوحات وايضا
الفتوحات عبر التاريخ الاسلامي غزوه بدر
كذلك
فتح مكه القادسيه بعد ذلك
اخر شيء في حرب رمضان 10 رمضان 1973 الحرب
العربيه الاسلاميه ضد الكيان الصهيوني وهي
معركه فاصله جاءت
لتاخذ الحق العربي والاسلامي الفلسطيني في
مواجهه الهزيمه 67
ولذلك قلنا بان رمضان شهر من حيث التدافع
الحضاري محطات تاريخيه واضحه كما ذكرنا
قبل قليل وكذلك من حيث من حيث من حيث
الانجاز المهني والعملي والعلمي والفكر
والادبي شهر رمضان بالاضافه لانه شهر صيام
هو ايضا شهر فكر وادب فعاليات ثقافيه او
حضاريه وشهر للتنميه الزراعيه شهر للاداء
الوظيفي المهني انا اذكر اختبرت
البكالوريا الثانويه العامه وانا في اجواء
شهر سته واختبرتوا امتحانات في الجامعه
ولست وانا فقط يعني طلاب الجامعات
والمدارس والمعاهد في كثير من المناسبات
الاختبارات الجامعيه والمدرسيه تكون في
شهر رمضان الفلاحون والمزارعون المسلمون
الذين يصومون في عز الحر وهم يحصدون
المزروع والذين يعملون في الحقل والذين
يعملون في السفر وفي هناك مسافرون يشتغلون
في سيارات اجره وفي سفر والتنقل مع ذلك
يصومون لانهم قادم على الصيام وكل الامه
الاسلاميه في مجموعها لا يمثل رمضان تحديا
للانجاز والعمل وانما رمضان يعطي القوه
المعنويه الروحيه اولا ويعطي كذلك القوه
الجسديه ولذلك نصح المسلم بان ياكل ويشرب
في ليل رمضان وان يتسحر لان السحور بركه
وان يعتني بغذائه المناسب اللازم وان ياخذ
قصته من الراحه لكن التطبيق لدى بعض
المسلمين في كثره السهر مثلا او في قله
الاكل او في اضطراب اكل او ما شابه ذلك
هذا طبعا يؤدي بهم في رمضان وفي غير رمضان
يؤدي نعم والاطباء اثبتوا اليوم ايضا
فوائد الصيام حتى اننا اصبحنا نسمع بداية
للصيام المتقطع وغيره يعني وهذا الصيام
المتقطع الدليل علمي واقعي على صلاحيه
الصوت الصوم ليس ليس الصوم امرا قديما
وانتهى الصوم هو سلوك انساني في
نظام الغذاء ونظام الشرب وفي نظام نفسي
وعقلي الى اخره هذا النظام الغذائي هذا
السلوك الغذائي مهم جدا في السلامه
الجسديه وفي الصحه وكذلك مهم في التوازن
الذي يؤدي الى نتائجه على مستوى الانجاز
والانتاج والتثمير والفعل الصوم متقطع ليس
صوم هو ليس حكما شرعيا يعني ليس عباده
انما هو سلوك طبي ينصح به لاغراض صحيه هذا
يدل على ان الصوم بمعنى انقطاع اكل وشرب
هذا يدل على صلاحيته على مشروعيته الذي
يتميز به الصوم الاسلامي هو النيه
واراده وجه الله تعالى والامت لامره نعم
دكتور نور الدين خلينا نعود تحدثنا عن
المشقه والفرصه والاختلافات وغيره خلينا
في الفرصه يقول رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
يقول اذا جاء رمضان فتحت ابواب الجنه
فكيف يتهيا المسلمون عاده لهذا الشهر
الكريم
للاستفاده من فوائده وفضائله هذا التهيؤ
والاستعداد لرمضان هو استعداد نفسي
واستعداد عقلي واستعداد جسدي وهو فردي
وجماعي بالنسبه الى الاستعداد النفسي هو
ان يتهيا الانسان بنفسه
لصيام هذا الشهر ان ينوي صيام هذا الشهر
ان يهنا بطمئن نفسيه وهو يستعد لهذا الشهر
الاستعداد العقلي هو ان يتذكر الاحكام
والاداب والمعارف المتعلقه بهذا الصح بهذا
الصيام هذا ما يتعلق بالعقل العقل بمعنى
الفهم فهم الايات فهم الاحكام فهم الاداب
الاسلاميه والاستعداد الجسدي هو ان يكون
في صحه وعافيه من شروط الصيام الصحه
ومن موانع الصيام المرض فالاسلام هنا يحرص
على ان يكون الانسان صحيحا جسديا وصحيحا
قلبيا بمعنى
نيه حسنه وقصد خالص لوجه الله تعالى وان
يكون صحيح العقل ان يفهم هذا الشهر فهما
صحيحا شهر ليس هو شهر مثلا للصحر الطويل
ليس هو شهر الاستهلاك دون الانتاج ليس هو
شهر ايضا للعباده المطلقه من غير ان ينتفع
باكل وشرب وان يتبسط بنوع من التبسط في
زياره في مادوبه غداء في فسحه في رفاهيه
الى اخره فالجمع بين هذه الحقائق كلها من
العلم والمعرفه بهذا الصيام وهذا يحتاج
الى استعداد
الاستعداد والتخطيط التخطيط مثلا هذا
استعداد الاسره مثل الاستعداد الاسره يعني
وانا جاي في الطريق معي اهلي وبنتي
بارك الله فيك بنت الصغرى قالت لي حدثهم
او اذكر لهم الاستعداد البيتي قلت له كيف
استعداد البيت قالت الاستعداد البيتي هو
ان الاسره مجموع الاسره يتهيا بهذا الشهر
اذا فيه اشياء
للاقتناء يفضل ان تقتنع قبل الشهر بهدوء
بفكر وتخطيط وايضا ان يعد هذا الشهر في
البيت من جهه الجزء الطبخ والاكل والشرب
من جهه زاويه العباده او ان يخصص ركن الذي
بنت تقول لهذا الكلام ان نخصص ركن نحط فيه
السجاده نحط فيه المصحف نقرا فيه القران
نصلي فيما كتب وايضا من جهه الاستعداد
العائلي على اجتماع على الطعام على السحور
استدعاء
قريباتنا اخواتي مثلا زوجات اخوات زوجتي
اقار بارحام الاحباب الزملاء ندعوهم وايضا
ان ندعى من قبلهم لمادبا او لاكثر في هذا
الشهر المبارك وايضا ان نتذكر ونتذكر
ابائنا وامهاتنا وتراثنا التونسي وتراثنا
القطري وتراث العربي والاسلامي وتراث
الانسان في هذا الشهر لان هذا الشهر ايضا
منتج تراثي عمراني حضاري ثقافي في فنون
وعلوم وفيه انتجات وفيه الفانوس مثلا
اقتناء الفانوس او المصباح او القنديل على
الاختلاف التسميات والهلال المجسم هذا
يعني انا نفس الشيء احنا من يومين يعني
العائله اقتنعت فانوس يعني وتقريبا كل سنه
يختنوا فانوس وهذا يقودنا دكتور نور الدين
هذه المحادثه الجميله بينك وبين بنتك
تقودنا للحديث عن عن السلف صالحا صحابه
الرسول الكرام رضي الله عنهم وكيف كانوا
يستقبلون هذا الشهر الكريم هذه هذا
الفانوس الهلال المقتنيات وغيره كانوا
يستقبلونه بكل فرحه
فهذه مظاهر الفرحه عنا اليوم ولذلك نحن
المفروض قراءتنا للتراث الاسلامي تركز على
المنتوج الحضاري والثقافي بالاضافه طبعا
الى المنتوج العلمي الشرعي في العلوم
الشرعيه وفي الاحكام الشرعيه
فيه له علوم وفيه مدونات ومنتجات كثيره
نحن لا نستوعبها كما هي والا فامتنا
الاسلاميه وتراثنا الواسع لان تراثنا
الاسلامي هذا تراث امه والامه هذه هي في
القارات الخمس فيها العرب والعجم وفيها
الشرق والغرب فيها يعني
ملايين المسلمين لان اكثر من مليار
وثمانون وعبر التاريخ ملايين مئه الملايين
كل هذه الامه لها منتوجات ثقافيه وحضاريه
في شهر رمضان لو نتطلع مثلا على دوله من
دول الاسلاميه في الشرق في الغرب في
الخليج في غرب في الغرب الاسلامي في شمال
افريقيا في كل هذه الدول سنجد من الفنون
والمنتجات الفانوس المصباح الى ماذا
يحيلنا الفانوس الفانوس يحيلنا الى
الاضاءه الى النور يحيلنا الى احياء الليل
الى احياء الليل لانه رمضان يحيى ليله
ويحيا نهاره ولكن احياء ليله ونهاره ليس
معنى ذلك ان لا ننام وان لا ناخذ قسطا من
الراحه نوع المعتاد اربع ساعات ست ساعات
سبع ساعات من اجل تجديد النشاط وايضا ان
نحي نهاره بعمل وانتاج ولذلك حتى اليوم
مقسم ثلاثه اجزاء ثمانيه عام وثمانيه راحه
هذا ينطبق في رمضان
ثمانيه ساعات او قريب من ذلك وينتج سبعه
ثمانيه ساعات ويرتاح سبعه ثمانيه ساعات
لذلك يشير الى قيام الليل والى التهجد
والى التراويح ويشير كذلك الى حركه
انسانيه ليليه في تواصل اجتماعي في انتاج
حضاري في عمل خاص في شان خاص فالفانوس
يذكرنا نحن الفانوس نستخدمه ليس للاناره
عن مشاعر الكهرمان
لكن عند فانوس تراثي
زينه وذاكره يحيي فينا قيمه قيام الليل
يحيثين احياء الليل يحيثين الاضاءه والنور
بهذه المستويات نحن تحدثنا على مستوى
الفرد الاسره ماذا عن بقيه الاطراف
الفاعله في المجتمع الاسلامي هناك جمعيات
هناك منظمات ناشطه خلال شهر رمضان بارك
الله فيك في هذا السؤال
استعداد الشعب والامه والدوله والجمعيات
لرمضان هو استعداد ضروري ومهم مثل استعداد
الاسره واستعداد اي فرض كيف يتصور استعداد
الدوله استعداد الدوله وفي التخطيط لهذا
الشهر لان هذا الشهر هو شهر اقتصادي فيه
الاستهلاك وفيه الانتاج لان الاستهلاك
مقابل الانتاج فانت تؤمن الدوله
وفق اعرافها وقوانينها ما يكون استهلاكا
وما يكون انتاجا وما يكون توقيتا اداريا
وانجازا حضاريا وانتظاما وطنيا في هذه
الدوله هذا من مسؤوليه الدوله ومن
الاستعداد ولذلك جرت عاده الدول الاسلاميه
ان تخطط لهذا الشهر وان تحضر المواد وان
تقيم برامج اعلاميه فيها الافاده او
البلاغات والتوجيه في المرور في السهر في
التمدرس في العمل الاداري الوظيفه الماليه
هذا استعداد الدوله وهذا من صميمي رمضان
لان الدوله ايضا تحتاج الى تخطيط والى
تنفيذ وتحتاج الى سوق فيها السلاح
والبضائع والى تنظيم الوقت والى اخره
استعداد المجتمع المدني او الاهلي هذا
ايضا مهم جدا عن طريق الجمعيات التي تنجز
اعمالا خيريه في هذا الشهر وجارات عاده
المسلمين وهذا من الاسلام ومن العادات
الحسنه انهم يقيمون
خيريه في شهر رمضان موارد الرحمن
موعد الافطار القفه
في تونس القفه قفه رمضان وهي عباره مجموعه
سله فيها غذائيه وفواكه مستلزمات الغداء
لاسبوع اكثر اقل وعنا كذلك ما يعرف
بالتازر بوجه عام والتضامن بوجه عام
الزيارات
الاعانات
اخراج الزكاه في شهر رمضان يصح في غير
رمضان يصح كذلك الاكثار من الصدقات
الاكثار من العطاء في هذا الشهر المبارك
اسقاط الديون او التنازل عن بعضها لان هذا
من الرحمه هو شهر رمضان شهر الرحمه فمن
رحم انسان باسقاط دينا اسقط الله عز وجل
عنه ذنبا وخطرا واثما فهذا استعداد
المجتمع واستعداد الدوله واستعداد الفرد
واستعداد الاسره مجموع هذا الاستعدادات
يمثل استعداد الامه طيب دكتور نور الدين
ما الضرر في حال عدم الاستعداد يعني
موجوده
ويتم الصيام الالتزام بكل شعائر رمضان
وغيره فاين الضرر لا يمكن الدخول لرمضان
من غير استعداد لانه بيدخل الى شهر جديد
فيه التزامات فيه اعمال تحتاج منه ترتيب
وقته عنده مثلا التراويح من ناحيه
العباديه عنده التراويح ليله رمضان وعنده
السحور في اول رمضان قبل في الفجر لابد
يعد هذا السحور وعنده عمل اداري بتوقيت
جديد وعنده انه سيفطر في عند الاذان يعني
عنده اعمال
واوضاعا تحتاجه تحتاجه منه تنظيما لهذا
اما ان يدخل هكذا اين النيه والنيه من
الاستعداد اين الاستعداد النفسي
والاستعداد العلمي اين الاستعداد الترتيبي
والتنظيم مثل ما قلنا له الدوله تدخل
رمضان غير استعداد مثل موسم دراسي او مثل
الحج يحجوا ما هو مش مستعد يعني كيف يحج
مش مستعد يعني عدم قد يؤدي الى التقصير في
كل هذه
العباده والى فوات العمل اصلا يعني هو لم
يستعد وقت السحور ولم يجد سحورا
سيتعب يوم كامل هو جاء المغرب وتذكر وقتها
باش يسوي للطعام يمشي وقتها يدور على
المحلات بعد العصر ما يحصلش وعندها تاتي
حشيشه رمضان كما نقول بتونسي دكتور نور
الدين وحشيشه رمضان هي انه الانسان يعصب
يعني ليت ملك اعصابه بسبب نزول مستوى
السكر في الدم والجوع هذه الحشيشه هي
مصطلح تونسي وهي حشيشه حلال هي حشيشه
تتعلق بالقهوه والشاي
فبعض الناس متعودون كل الناس متعودون على
شرب القهوه وشرب الشاي في الصباح وفي
اوقات مختلفه من النهار لكنهم في رمضان لا
يشربون هذه القهوه وهذا الشيء الا في
الليل فيصبحون على هذه الحشيشه يقول لك
يعدل الدماغ والمخ الا قهوه في الصباح او
شيء هذه ايش معنى حشيشه رمضان في اطلاقنا
التونسي هي حشيشه بمعنى عاده تتعلق بشرب
قهوه او شرب الشاي فيحرم الانسان منها في
نهار رمضان ولكن له قضاء الفئه في الليل
كان يشرب في النهار قهوتي
الحمدلله وايضا هذا من من الثبات والصبر
لانه هذا الكبح للشهوه المشروعه
ضمن مبادئ الاسلام وهذا احنا جربناه
والناس
يشعرون بهذه الحشيشه وخاصه في اليوم الاول
او في اليومين الاولين لكن بعد ذلك
يتعودون سبحان الله يعني الصبر على العطش
والجوع
بل بعد انتهى رمضان في اول عيد وثاني عيد
تكون عندهم حشيشه رمضان يعني متعودوا على
الصيام فيعودون
سبحان الله شهر الخيرات شهر البركات
الدكتوره نور الدين اذا هذا الشهر بالنسبه
لسلف الصالح كما تحدثنا يتسابقون فيه على
الطاعات يتزحمون فيه على فعل الخيرات
والعمل الصالح فما هي رسالتك الى الخلف
الدكتور نور الدين خاصه وان بعضهم قد تجرا
على هذا الركن العظيم من اركان الاسلام
تحت غطاء الحريات وغيرها هذا الشهر
المبارك في رساله الى الامه والى اجيالنا
المعاصره هذا الشهر هو الشهر المنافسه في
الخير
تعظيم العطاء تعظيم هذه الشعيره لانها
شعيره عبديه عقائديه الله سبحانه وتعالى
خلقنا وامرنا بصيام هذا الشهر وجعل ذلك
عباده له كل عمل ابن كل عمل لابن ادم له
الا الصوم فانه لي وانا اجزي به هذا الشهر
شهر المنافسه في المدارسه ومن حقائق رمضان
انه شهر المدارسه كما هو شهر التلاوه
المدارسه هنا يقصد بها مدارسه القران
والمسلمون كما يقراون القران وكما يختمونه
والختمه الاولى والثانيه واكثر لابد ان
يتدارسوه ان يفهموا هذه الايات فهما
جماعيا وفرديا بقراءه الكتاب التفسيري
بحضور مجالس التفسير وايضا مدارسه هنا
بمعنى مدارسه السنه وبمعنى ايضا المدارسه
النافعه في مجموعها كل ما هو علم نافع
ودراسه فيها خير للامه في بناء حضاره في
تطوير منتج في تحقيق العداله في تمتين
ليس الذي هو كل رمضان ان نضيع اوقات كثيره
في السهر والسمر والمسلسلات
والفوازير وفي الحديث الكثير وفي النقاشات
التي ليس لها معنى هذا كله على خلاف حقيقه
رمضان ليس معنى ذلك ان الانسان لا يلتفت
الى الوان من الوان الترفيه المشروع وان
لا ياتي على اجره وثوابه لان الله سبحانه
وتعالى يقول ولا تبطل اعمالكم رسالتك
دكتور نور الدين هي لهذا الخلاف للاجيال
الحاليه من المسلمين هو اقتنس هذه الفرصه
لان رمضان فرصه الى دخول الجنه رمضان فرصه
لتحقيق الرحمه الالهيه رمضان فرصه عظيمه
جدا ونادره ورمضان كما قلت ضيف خفيف سرعان
ما يمر هذه الفرصه نتخذها ونغتنمها بكل ما
فيها وفعلا الذين صاموا العمل الماضي هم
الذين ماتوا هم الان في في عند ربهم
سبحانه وتعالى ولا ندري في رمضان القادم
من يكون في اهل الاخره لذلك طالما نحن
احياء نغتنم هذا الشهر باعمال خير بتعظيم
الشعيره وباراده مراد الله سبحانه وتعالى
والله ولي التوفيق وتحياتي مره اخرى
ودعواتي لكل الامه بان يبلغ هذا الشهر
بقبول وصحه وعافيه وسلامه تامه دائمه
اللهم امين نسال الله في ختام هذه الحلقه
ان يبلغنا رمضان
وان يرزقنا صيامه وقيامه ايمانا واحتسابا
الدكتور نور الدين الخادمي رئيس وحده
البحوث بجامعه قطر ووزير شؤون الدينيه
السابق في تونس شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه
الحلقه المفيده بارك الله فيك رمضان مبارك
متابعينا والى اللقاء كان هذا بعد امس
[موسيقى]